what's happening there reject nation greg and john
here today guys looks like we are finally getting
joker 2 the follow-up to the walking phoenix todd
phillips directed movie 44 oscar nominations that
previous one got one of the highest grossing rated
moves of all time is it the highest or one of
yeah so with that in mind you know like they're
talking about how they're aiming for like a 2023
shoot time and then so we probably get a release
this movie around 2024 to 2025 so the script is
still in early development stages there was a part
of me that always wondered whether or not this
movie would actually come true it seemed like this
would be a good standalone movie and knowing that
todd phillips and joaquin phoenix were both really
insistent on not having this joker cross paths
with batman to keep it very character focused on
arthur fleck seemed like the story might have been
done for them to return gives me hope that they
are developing a story that has to be worthwhile
for them to actually return or it's just money i
can't turn down that boatload of chaos and i had
the second highest rated movie too yeah exactly
so with that in mind of course there are not a
lot of plot details out there but there are rumors
about lady gaga possibly joining the cast so i do
want to talk about what that role could possibly
be a little bit later but first what i wanted to
dive into is an idea that i've had for what they
could do for joker 2 for quite a while i've had
it for a few years in fact i was a guest star like
a few years ago on movie fights screen junkies and
one of the questions was what would you do for a
joker too and that was actually one of the easiest
questions i've ever had because i'm like i knew
i know exactly what i would want to do for a joke
or two so i kind of wanted to share that pitch
with you guys talk about it a little bit because
you know they're in the early draft stages so you
know todd phillips if you guys are listening you
kind of like where i'm going with this you know
you need some rewrites feel free to feel free to
just steal something i don't care just still
steal it and i just want to see it come true
i've had this log line written down forever just
the log line so i just want to read it my basic
pitch for this would be after becoming a celebrity
worship serial killer receiving fan letters and
arkham and such the absentee leader of the cult
breaks arthur fleck out to lead their cause but
they find a difference in ideologies they perceive
from arthur versus arthur's actual motives i call
this the cult of joker because if you look at
the events what happened in the movie joker
he had his own personal agenda with the kills that
he did those people he killed on the subway the
cult following though the ones that started all
the riots and such the ones that worshiped him
at the very end their ideas are focused more on
the one percent and the corruption the capitalism
the politicians they pretty much misinterpreted
his actions in that movie as being something more
profound on the talk show with robert de niro he
directly says i'm not political he doesn't have an
agenda in that movie did this to start a movement
to become a symbol do i look like the kind of
clown that could start a movement i killed those
guys because they were awful his personal motives
though when he did kill they gave credence to
these riots and so what i imagine is that in this
like cult following not everyone in that group is
an unhinged mentally ill person like arthur per se
but they still interpreted him as sort of a robin
hood fighting against the evil men in power right
that's why they loved him so much so what happens
when you break that person out this way you can
segue arthur reflect because he doesn't fully arc
into the joker that we sort of expect yes is he
delusional is he a little bit psychopathic sure
but he doesn't become the criminal mastermind in
that film which is what the joker is a criminal
mastermind still an unhinged anarchist so you
could segue from him being who he was in arkham
by the end of that movie into becoming a criminal
leader criminal mastermind because by the end of
joker 1 he receives this love and validation from
the people at the end of joker but in this sequel
instead of like revolting to lead the people
in poverty the people who are angry with the one
percent at gotham you find out he actually doesn't
give a [ __ ] about that like he doesn't care
about them he never did you know makes sense you
watch this mentally ill unstable man evolve into
the master manipulator the criminal mastermind
the selfish thief in the underworld of gotham
bringing anarchy to the streets keep the joker
isms but maintain the themes of the first joker
movie not just put batman in here no i feel like
that would cheapen everything and you could do
yeah so much more interesting work with just the
psychological yeah motivations of arthur fleck and
how it affects the world around him and the fact
that he is coming from such a place of isolation
and probably a lot of people who do follow him now
are probably the kinds of people he would not get
along with exactly so like what if by the end of
the journey the ones who ultimately loved him who
he found acceptance through ultimately abandoned
him his symbol is stripped away and he becomes a
villain feared by the people of gotham goes from
pure psychopath into criminal mastermind i think
that could be like kind of the midpoint of the
film actually it could be a breaking act too sure
but we're hearing these rumors about lady gaga
now as much as i've been like i don't know about
batman coming in here i i know some people want
that but i don't i don't think so i feel like
todd phillips and walking phoenix were never truly
interested in it and in a lot of ways i feel like
even for someone like myself who highly recommends
joker some of the bruce wayne stuff felt a little
bit like and we really need it like thomas wayne
felt necessary but bruce do we really need that
man stick his hands in your mouth when we're
looking at who lady gaga might be i'm not opposed
to the idea of her actually being harlene quinzel
in arkham asylum because we haven't gotten the
movie yet that really allows you to deep dive in
to him manipulating harleen quinzel into becoming
harley quinn does she even need to go full arc
in that terrain no but you can if you watch
like lady gaga and even american horror story
like american horror story hotel i know she's in
roanoke but that doesn't mean let's get's going
like more for a hotel but you've seen her do like
a star wars morning she's got a lot of praise for
house of gucci she would bring something very
different a different flavor that i think could
match what joaquin phoenix was doing with his more
realistic grounded interpretation of the character
and we could actually see their relationship
really develop from psychologist to patient
really see how that forms and how ultimately the
patient ends up taking control of the psychologist
lady gaga would actually be a great fit for that i
don't think she needs to become like harley quinn
by the end but it would be a cool character to
just have her be the doctor in that film oh yeah
i think that would be part of the charm because
the original it would suit the original joker's
rise to the point where yeah maybe by the end she
does have some kind of break but you're not going
into full super villainy territory and two i mean
i feel like the first movie is such a character
study of one person you could do the folia do
then in the second movie and yeah see what happens
when that person maybe connects legitimately to
somebody because you could get a lot of confusing
feelings coming out of arthur fleck but then also
that tragic manipulation of harleen quinzel of the
one person trying to give him the benefit of the
doubt maybe or at least getting through to him a
little bit you know like i feel like there are a
lot of very big and broad ways a joker two could
go but that feels like a really nicely uh honed
in and contained way of exploring just as twisted
personal territory yeah so that way you keep it
criminal focused you still keep it within the tone
and the themes of the first one and then you could
get a little harley quinn easter egg in there too
but i don't know i mean they already obviously
have a plan in mind i just don't want it to
become comic book movie yeah that's the point is
you got to keep it yeah feeling still like kind of
a 70s like slightly broaching on that you know
heightened territory but still keeping it really
grounded and and icky anyway yeah we don't have
any details on what this movie would ultimately
be but so i just wanted to throw out there what
i sort of fantasized about what joker two could
possibly turn into so i guess we'll just wait
and see when the official teaser trailer or
plot synopsis ultimately comes out but guys what
would you want them to do with joker 2 throwing
the question to you guys uh this was just like
a fun little fan theory video i wanted to throw
out there so you can subscribe click that bell hit
that like button and hey we'll catch you guys soon